as we begin our journey into the Cthulhu
Mythos in the works of HP Lovecraft I
was immediately faced of a dilemma the
dilemma of where I should begin but
after some contemplation there was only
one real answer with the great sleeper
himself the great dreamer of early a the
great Cthulhu now having an entire
mythos named after him you'd expect
Cthulhu to heavily feature in numerous
works of Lovecraft but that isn't the
case cathedrals or the appearance of any
your own notes was of course in the Call
of Cthulhu the story itself is told from
varying accounts and the style is quite
similar to something you'd expect from a
documentary using the letters and
manuscripts of several characters it is
from the Norwegian sailor Gustav
Johansson that we are provided of a
first-hand account of his terrifying
encounter with Cthulhu with your Hansen
and the rest of his crew awaking Cthulhu
from his slumber realizing the mistake
they had made they attempted to flee but
many of them are slaughtered in the
process eventually Johansson and the
rest of the crew decide that they have
to face the monster head-on Ramen
airboat straight into Cthulhu at first
this appear to have worked
spitting Cthulhu's head open however
upon seeing the great old one regenerate
and begin to reform they realized that
this was a beast unlike any they had
encountered previously and decided it
were best to evacuate new Hansen
survived long enough for his accounts
for the terrifying events that took
place that day to be found and arguably
this is where our fascination with
Cthulhu began Lovecraft only mentioned
Cthulhu in the great old ones in passing
he created a very loose Pantheon
consistent of ancient deities that were
not from our world it wasn't until the
later years when writers such as August
Derleth
Robert E Howard Neil Gaiman Robert Bloch
and a host of others really began to
develop the ideas that Lovecraft had
introduced the name cthulhu's beliefs
have derived from the classical Greek
word cathodic
meaning subterranean which refers to
something that exists under the Earth's
surface being secret and concealed which
is a description of its Cthulhu quite
well considering he could be found
sleeping deep beneath the Pacific Ocean
as I mentioned in my previous video
about Lovecraft Cthulhu was actually
meant to be pronounced in an alien
tongue Lovecraft himself used several
different pronunciations over the years
was the most common being claw all but
as you can imagine talking in an alien
tongue just isn't very practical
especially when it sounds like you're
about to cough up a fur ball so the
pronunciation that is widely accepted
and used today is of course Cthulhu in
the years of followed La Crosse parson
there were dozens of authors that
included Cthulhu in their stories and a
10
just for one backstory to consider
cannon doesn't really work there were
numerous authors have described Cthulhu
in a variety of different ways with his
personality motives and appearance
varying in their own unique manner and
to me that's what makes the work of
Lovecraft LaRose that followed so great
we have the Space Foundation that's been
laid by Lovecraft
but all of these characters can be
interpreted in the way you see best so I
guess what I'll be discussing is the few
things that people mostly agree on we
know that the great old ones are
described as coming from the Stars but
what exactly does that mean
Cthulhu whose beliefs have been born on
the planet of all located in the 23rd
nebula he is part of an alien race known
as the great old ones the Cthulhu was
never really considered a God like the
rest of them he was instead considered a
priest with one of his many titles being
Cthulhu high priests of the great old
ones Cthulhu is described by Lovecraft
has been neither male or female though
in the later years the sentiment emerged
that he was the brother and father of
himself as he impregnates his daughter
Cthulhu Cthulhu is referred to as a
female so because of this I'll be
referring to Cthulhu as a he for the
rest of the video
Cthulhu was a child of nug and yep
making his grandparents yokes are Thoth
and shebna Grove meaning his great
grandparent was as a thot
Cthulhu did have numerous children and
when traveling to the planet of zoth he
came across
edia whom he would mate with creating
for children Gitana thora the dark
golden the firstborn of Cthulhu yoke
saga the second son zoth amok the third
son and Casilla the secret one the
daughter toss will regenerate in her
father should he ever be slain
accompanying Cthulhu and his children as
they traveled the universe was the star
spawn of Cthulhu a shape-shifting alien
race that resembled Cthulhu there were
much smaller and science whether these
beings were the actual spawn of Cthulhu
or just an alien species that was
similar in appearance that chose to
worship the priest is unknown when
Cthulhu and his followers arrived on
earth they built the great city of early
a a city built of enormous emerald
stones and statues that honored the
great Cthulhu a city that was often
referred to as the great corpse city of
early a not long after arriving they
encountered an alien species known as
the elder ones or the elder things which
had colonized and lived on earth for
over a billion years the elder ones in
the star spawn of Cthulhu went to war
and despite their numerous conflicts
they eventually agreed to live in peace
together Cthulhu and his star spawn
would have reign over the newly formed
land masses and they Alda wanted all the
ancient land masses around the regions
of Antarctica
who eventually fell into a deep slumber
and watched over human civilization as
they advanced and developed over the
years he did however maintain contact of
humankind through their dreams and
slowly began to create the cult of
Cthulhu the great city of earlier would
eventually sink into the depths of the
sea for reasons that many have
speculated about ranging from alien
attacks to natural disaster Cthulhu and
his children remain trapped waiting for
a time when the ancient city would
resurface the cult of Cthulhu were left
waitin for the sunken city of earlier to
rise and for the great old ones and
mankind to finally become one with so
many deities that featured in his mythos
and a bunch that came before Cthulhu why
exactly is Cthulhu the most well known
to us and why does he have an entire
mythos named after him
I've yet to mention the appearance of
Cthulhu and that's because I feel
Cthulhu's appearance is one of the main
reasons that he became so popular many
of the deities are featuring a Cthulhu
Mythos often appear as a combination of
tentacles eyeballs and bubbling goo and
to be honest half the time it's quite
difficult to distinguish between the
deities this is an issue that we don't
have of Cthulhu despite the fact that he
features in tons of stories from all
sorts of universes and time periods his
appearance remains extremely
recognizable in the Call of Cthulhu he's
described as being a monster with a
vague anthropoid outline and that boid
meaning it somewhat resembles an ape or
a human his head was that of an octopus
with a host of tentacles acting as
feelers he had claws on each hand and
each foot with a pair of very basic
wings that didn't look like they were
capable of flight the main defining
feature of Cthulhu is the fact that he
just looks like a giant octopus man with
tentacles around in his mouth and no I'm
not referring to Davy Jones the autistic
interpretations of Cthulhu vary as much
as the stories he features in the
weather he appears as a giant statue or
a cartoon character he remains very easy
to tell that what you are looking at is
in fact Cthulhu now for anything like me
you may not be a huge fan of the ocean
or more specifically what we cannot see
in the depths below the frost work is
based of the fear of the unknown the
fear of these unknown powerful beings
that we are unaware of if you combine
this fear with a really existent fear
that we have such as what lies beneath
the ocean you now have a fear that is
familiar but yet still unknown making it
easier to understand and relate to which
is exactly what we have of Cthulhu many
would regard a monster such as Cthulhu
as innately evil but he's a being that
we cannot truly comprehend a being whose
motives and ethics we will never
understand he is neither good nor bad
the roms have good and bad as we know it
do not
- Cthulhu Cthulhu has become somewhat of
a staple in pop culture there is an
endless list of games movies and books
that feature Cthulhu and his mythos if
there are any stories that you've
recently read that feature Cthulhu that
you think might be worth sharing then
please do so in the comments below if
enough people agree then there may be a
future reading as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained
you